cuando tenemos una economía normal
sucede que el empleo impulsa la demanda
si tenemos alto nivel de empleo o bajo
desempleo entonces las personas van a
tener más empleos salarios más altos y
por ende habrá más demanda si sucede lo
contrario la demanda bajará habrá menos
salarios y por ende las personas tendrán
menos dinero en los bolsillos entonces
tenemos que el empleo impulsa la demanda
y a su vez la demanda impulsa la
producción o lo que podemos llamar o
pensar como oferta y también la demanda
impulsa el precio y claro aquí hay un
pequeño circuito de retroalimentación
negativa para ambas la demanda y la
oferta si la demanda es alta y el precio
es alto eso puede producir
retroalimentación negativa en la demanda
en lugar de poner una flecha voy a poner
aquí este símbolo para representar
retroalimentación negativa y por otro
lado digamos que la demanda es alta y la
oferta es alta
eso hace eso conduce la oferta alta hace
que el precio baje entonces aquí tenemos
retroalimentación negativa alta demanda
conduce a bajar precios ahora lo
menciono sin embargo no me quiero
enfocar en esto en el vídeo podríamos
seguir agregando flechas pero la
principal idea es que la oferta y la
demanda la oferta y la demanda conducen
a utilidades corporativas lo pongo como
utilidades y las utilidades conducirán
nuevamente al empleo ahora imagina que
tenemos depresión económica entonces en
esta situación yo podría iniciar en
cualquier punto del círculo por ejemplo
podría iniciar en empleo si yo tengo
bajo empleo tengo entonces baja demanda
esto me conduce a tener baja oferta y
bajos precios si yo tengo baja oferta y
bajos precios entonces tengo utilidades
bajas y aún menos desempleo entonces nos
hallamos aquí en este entorno recesivo
este entorno de depresión económica y a
eso se le llama una espiral
deflacionaria y es una espiral es una
espiral porque una mala economía nos
está conduciendo a bajar precios y los
precios bajos a su vez nos están
conduciendo en retorno a una baja
economía si esta situación continúa las
personas tendrán dinero pero no querrán
gastarlo porque una pueden perder el
trabajo en cualquier momento y dos
porque ese dinero tendrá más valor por
cada minuto que pasa ahora mientras
todas estas cosas terroríficas suceden
el empleo baja las utilidades bajan los
precios bajan esto hace que las personas
no acumulen bienes y servicios o al
menos no como lo harían en un espiral
inflacionario pero hace que acumulen
dinero lo cual es ultra espantoso para
los banqueros centrales y el gobierno
porque éstos inician a perder el control
sobre la economía y no simplemente
pueden imprimir dinero tratando de
estimular dinero en esta situación
porque si lo hicieran
son tan conservadoras en estos días
puedes imaginar la depresión por años y
años y digamos que toman un helicóptero
y bueno así no es como cómo se
distribuye el dinero pero usemos este
ejemplo extremo y empieza a lanzar
dinero voló a todas las personas hombre
mujer y niño cada uno con un billete de
diez en el bolsillo pero las personas
tienen tanto miedo que solo van a tomar
ese billete lo van a poner bajo el
colchón y nada cambiará ese billete no
no entrará como recurso su velocidad
será cero y así funciona la espiral
deflacionaria